imaginemos que tenemos una partícula que
se está moviendo a lo largo de una recta
numérica por aquí tengo la recta
numérica en la que se mueve la partícula
digamos que la partícula empieza aquí en
el cero y se va a la izquierda luego la
derecha luego regresa no se hace toda
clase de locuras y de hecho nos dicen
que la posición de la partícula como una
función del tiempo t en segundos está
dada por la función s dt
t al cubo menos 6 de cuadrada más 9 t
esa es la función que nos da la posición
de la partícula en cualquier instante
sale de cero y no sé hacia dónde se
mueva pero bueno vamos a suponer también
que nos vamos a restringir a tiempos
positivos así que voy a pedir que te sea
mayor o igual a cero bueno y me
preguntan cuando la partícula va más
rápido cuando
cuándo
va más rápido la partícula
más rápido
ahora observen que esta es una pregunta
totalmente distinta a cuando la
partícula tiene más velocidad porque la
rapidez no tome en cuenta la dirección y
la velocidad sí es decir la velocidad si
voy hacia la derecha es positiva pero si
voy hacia la izquierda es negativa en
cambio la rapidez no tome en cuenta esa
dirección así que tendría dos escenarios
si estoy yendo hacia la derecha si estoy
yendo hacia la derecha lo cual
significaría que mi velocidad vedete es
mayor que cero entonces para ir más
rápido mi aceleración también tiene que
ser positiva mi aceleración
dt también tiene que ser positiva de ese
modo cada vez voy más y más rápido pero
qué pasa si por el contrario voy hacia
la izquierda
si me muevo hacia la izquierda entonces
mi velocidad de dt
tiene que ser negativa que me estoy
moviendo hacia el lado negativo de la
recta numérica pero para ir más rápido
que significa pues significa que mi
velocidad se tiene por así decirlo que
hacer aún más negativa por lo tanto la
aceleración la aceleración de la
partícula también tiene que ser menor
que cero entonces esas son las dos
situaciones que vamos a analizar ahora
cómo podemos hacer eso pues recuerden
que la velocidad de una partícula es el
cambio entre su posición y el tiempo la
tasa de cambio instantánea entre la
posición que es ese y el tiempo así que
la velocidad en cada instante está dada
por d s / de t el cambio instantáneo en
la posición dividido entre el cambio
instantáneo en el tiempo y esto que es
pues esto no es otra cosa más que por un
lado esto es la velocidad de dt y por el
otro lado esto es simplemente la
derivada de s
con respecto del tiempo s prima de t así
que para esta función de posición esta
de aquí cuál es la velocidad pues la
velocidad de esa partícula sería la
derivada de esto que sería t al cubo su
derivada es
bueno vamos a ponerle verde es igual a
la deriva de al cubo que sería 3 de
cuadrada menos la derivada de 6 t
cuadrada que sería menos 12 t
más la derivada en nombre de que sería 9
así que es la velocidad vamos a tratar
de graficar la para entender qué está
sucediendo primero que nada noten que en
el 0 b de 0 es igual a 9 por lo tanto es
la intersección con nuestro eje vertical
y para encontrar las intersecciones con
el eje horizontal el eje de el tiempo
vamos a igualar esto a 0 vamos a decir
que 3 t cuadrada menos 12 de más 9 es
igual a cero y si hago esto entonces
puedo dividir todo entre 3 y escribirlo
como de cuadrada menos 2 entre 3 a 4
menos 49 entre 3 es a 3 t cuadrada menos
cuatro temas 3 es igual a cero y esto es
muy fácil de factorizar porque lo que
quiero hacer es encontrar dos números
cuyo producto hacia 3 positivo y cuya
suma sea menos 4 entonces serían menos
tres y menos uno así que te menos 3 y te
menos uno debe de ser igual
pero para que este producto hacia cero
algunos de los factores tiene que ser
cero por lo tanto usted es igual a tres
y t es igual a uno
más bien usted es igual a uno
me lo escribo más bonito es igual a 1
muy bien y esas son las intersecciones
con el eje horizontal ahora sí vamos a
hacer la gráfica
vamos a tratar de hacer la gráfica vamos
a ver
es que aquí pongo mi eje vertical que va
a ser el eje de mi velocidad verde t
y por acá pongo el eje horizontal que va
a ser el eje de el tiempo wiesel choco
un poco pero bueno vamos a poner aquí
está el 1 2 y el 3
bien entonces yo sé que la partícula
cuando t es igual a 0 tiene velocidad 9
déjenme esto no va a estar escala así
que el 9 de estar por aquí en este eje
no va a estar cada escala con relación
este eje
bueno entonces en cero la partícula está
aquí en uno la partícula tiene velocidad
cero y / es la partícula también tiene
velocidad cero así que como el
coeficiente de t cuadrada estrés
yo sé que esta ecuación describe una
parábola que abre hacia arriba por lo
tanto el vértice tiene que estar aquí en
dos en dos y que qué velocidad tiene la
partícula en dos segundos después de que
inició su recorrido pues ve de dos sería
lo mismo que tres por dos al cuadrado
que sería tres por cuatro que es 12
menos 12 por 2 que sería menos 24 más 9
y cuánto es esto 12 menos 24 es menos 12
más 9
- 12 9 es menos 3 así que la partícula
estará por aquí más o menos en ese
instante de modo que la gráfica en la
velocidad se ve algo así
bueno algo así es la gráfica de la
velocidad de la partícula bueno cuando
va más rápido la partícula pues
recordemos que la aceleración a de t
que sería la aceleración es el cambio
instantáneo de la velocidad con respecto
al tiempo así que es debe entre dt pero
qué es esto pues esto es la derivada de
la velocidad de la función de velocidad
respecto al tiempo o lo que es lo mismo
la segunda derivada de la posición con
respecto al tiempo bueno vamos a hacer
primero este caso donde tiene la
partícula velocidad negativa pues tiene
velocidad negativa sobre todo todo este
intervalo de aquí
del 1 al 3 ahí tiene velocidad negativa
y donde su aceleración también es
negativa pues para que la aceleración
sea negativa entonces tiene que ser en
la parte en donde la función es
decreciente porque la aceleración es la
derivada de la velocidad así que donde
tiene pendiente negativa esta curva
donde su tangente tiene pendiente
negativa pues donde es decreciente y
donde es decreciente y además negativa
pues solo sobre este intervalo de aquí
este intervalo de aquí
entre el 1 y el 2 y la pendiente de la
tangente es negativa y la función de
velocidad también es negativa por lo
tanto la función está yendo más rápido
la partícula va más rápido con estas
condiciones cuando uno es menor que t
que es menor que 2 sobre este cachito de
aquí ahora este lado cuando la partícula
tiene velocidad positiva pues tiene
velocidad positiva sobre este lado
este lado hasta aquí y luego por acá
y donde además la aceleración es
positiva pues donde esta función es
creciente pues de este lado de este lado
de aquí es creciente por lo tanto esta
condición se va a cumplir
cuando la partícula esté sobre este lado
de la parábola más bien cuando la
velocidad esté sobre este lado de la
parábola y eso se da cuando t es mayor
que 3 entonces cuando va más rápido la
partícula cuando uno es menor que t y es
menor que 2 entre el segundo 1 y el
segundo 2 ahí va más rápido hacia la
izquierda
también cuando t es mayor que 3 y ahí va
más rápido hacia la derecha